>> Greg: WELL SHE THINKS SHE'S
A MAVERICK, HE DRIVES INTO
ONCOMING TRAFFIC.
YEAH, HE'S TRYING TO COP A PLEA.
IT'S ALL MOST THE PERFECT
SETTING FOR A NEW SITCOM.
♪ ♪
>> HE'S INSIDE TRADING!
AND EVERYONE SAYS SHE'S SO
CONNIVING WHILE HE'S DRUNK
DRIVING.
AND WHEN THERE'S TROUBLE
OVERSEAS FROM CONFLICTS WITH THE
TAIWANESE, IT'S THE PELOSI'S,
BABY!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, STANDING
OVER THERE, I TOLD JEAN CAN YOU
MAKE SOMETHING TRULY AWFUL, AND
HE SAID I'LL GIVE IT A SHOT.
AND HE FORGOT TO PUT THE LITTLE
LITTLE -- THERE'S NO --
INTERESTING.
IT SOUNDS LIKE AN ILLNESS.
ANYWAY, AS YOU KNOW, NANCY LEFT
TAIWAN ON WEDNESDAY AFTER
MEETING WITH LAWMAKERS AND
OFFERING U.S. SUPPORT FOR THE
ISLAND THAT CHINA CLAIMS AS ITS
OWN.
CHINA HAD THREATENED A FORCEFUL
RESPONSE IF SHE VISITED AND THEY
RAMPED UP THEIR LIVE FIRE DRILLS
AROUND TAIWAN UPON HER ARRIVAL.
THEY ALSO THREATENED TO SHOOT
WOODEN STAKES AND GARLIC AT HER
PLANE.
BUT SHE WAVED IT OFF AND EVEN
TOOK A JAB AT CHINA'S PRESIDENT.
>> WHATEVER CHINA WAS GOING TO
DO THEY WILL DO IN THEIR OWN
GOOD TIME.
THERE WERE CERTAIN SECURITY IS
ON THE PART OF THE PRESIDENT OF
CHINA AND HIS OWN CLINICAL
SITUATION THAT HE'S RATTLING THE
SABRES, I DON'T KNOW.
>> Greg: RATTLING HIS SABER?
FOR MOST OF US -- BEING THAT SHE
IS 120 YEARS OLD, SHE MEANS IT
LITERALLY.
BOTTOM LINE, NANCY IS SPARKING
CONFLICT WITH CHINA AFTER
TELLING EVERYONE ELSE TO SHUT UP
ABOUT CHINA.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE SAME
PERSON WHO SAID IT WAS RACIST TO
CALL KOVIC OVER THE CHINA VIRUS
AND TOLD OUR LIBYANS TO KEEP
QUIET DURING THE GAMES.
>> I WOULD SAY TO OUR ATHLETES,
YOU ARE THERE TO COMPETE.
DO NOT RISK INCURRING THE ANGER
OF THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT,
BECAUSE THEY ARE RUTHLESS.
>> Greg: I CALL HER A TO FACE
BUT THAT WAS FOUR FACES AGO.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
THEY LOVE THAT.
SO HER VISIT MAY DO NOTHING MORE
THAN CREATE CONFLICT WITH CHINA
WHICH MEANS THEY WILL COZY UP
WITH RUSSIA, BUT MAYBE THE TRIP
WILL PAY DIVIDENDS.
AT LEAST UNTIL THE STOCKS -- FOR
THE STOCKS HER HUSBAND BOB.
THERE'S NEW DETAILS ABOUT HIS
DUI ARREST.
COURT DOCUMENTS REVEAL HE HAD A
DRUG IN HIS SYSTEM, WAS SLURRING
HIS SPEECH AND HANDED COP A HELA
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL DONOR
CARD, SO IT LOOKS LIKE HE TRIED
TO WEASEL HIS WAY OUT BECAUSE HE
KNEW HE WOULD FAIL THE SOBRIETY
TEST.
AND REALLY HE HAD NO EXCUSE TO
DRINK.
HIS WIFE WAS 3,000 MILES AWAY.
TERRIBLE.
WHAT A JERK FOR USING THAT
PRIVILEGE CARD.
THOSE SHOULD BE RESERVED FOR
AVERAGE JOE'S AND NOT FOR PEOPLE
IN POWER.
>> NO.
NO.
NO MORE MICROWAVING FISH AT THE
OFFICE, WE'VE HAD ENOUGH.
>> I GOT NEWS FOR YOU, PAL.
I CAN DO WHATEVER I WANT.
>> YOU MICROWAVE ALL THE FISH
YOU WANT.
>> THIS GUY -- NANCY PELOSI.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SO, KAT, YOU KNOW IT
GETS ME -- I WAS THINKING ABOUT
THIS THIS MORNING, PELOSI GOING
TO A COUNTRY TO PROVOKE AN ENEMY
IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY KEPT SAYING
TRUMP WAS GOING TO DO, THAT HE
WAS GOING TO PROVOKE OUR
ENEMIES, HE'S UNSTABLE.
HE COULD START WORLD WAR III!
AND WHAT HAPPENS?
WE ARE BASICALLY IN WAR WITH
RUSSIA RIGHT NOW, AND WE'RE
TRYING TO SPARK CONFLICT WITH
CHINA.
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
I MEAN, HER TRIP -- WHAT DID HER
GOING THERE DO TO MAKE ANYONE
SAFER OR TO HELP TAIWAN AT ALL?
IF ANYTHING IT JUST PISSED CHINA
OFTEN COULD'VE AT THE OPPOSITE
EFFECT BUT IT MAKES HER LOOK
GOOD AND MAKES HER LOOK TOUGH
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT ALL OF
THIS IS ABOUT.
PLUS, YOU JUST CAN'T -- HER
HUSBAND, YOU CAN'T REALLY -- I
DON'T KNOW, YOU CAN'T REALLY
TRUST THEM.
THE BEST GUESTS IN THE WORLD IN
THE FINANCE RELEASE AND HE
COULDN'T GUESS HE SHOULDN'T
DRIVE HOPPED UP ON BOOZE AND
PILLS?
AND THEY'RE PROBABLY FIGHTING A
LOT.
SCREAMING AT EACH OTHER, BUT
THEY DECIDE TO STAY TOGETHER AND
RAISE THEIR INVESTMENTS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YES, THEY ARE STAYING
TOGETHER.
>> YEAH!
>> Greg: THEY SAY THAT, STAY
TOGETHER FOR THE INVESTMENTS.
>> THEIR EVENTUAL CAPITALIST
NEEDS BOTH PARENTS.
>> Greg: YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP
THAT BEAUTIFUL MANSION CLEAN,
TYRUS.
>> IF IT AIN'T BROKE...
>> Greg: THE THING IS, SHE
NEVER CARED ABOUT BEING -- I
GUESS BEING BRAVE AGAINST CHINA,
SHE WAS TELLING EVERYBODY NOT TO
BE.
>> CUT HER SOME SLACK.
IT'S NEVER GOOD TO GO TO A
COUNTRY DURING AN INVASION
SEASON.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A WHOLE THING,
REFUGEES ON THE BEACH AND STUFF.
YOU KNOW IT'S TOUGH, WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET A TAN.
LISTEN, I THINK SHE WENT ON A
SHOPPING SPREE.
THE SPOT IS HOT, SHE BROUGHT A
BUNCH OF EMPTY SUITCASES IN
AIR FORCE TO WHEN GOT TO GET
TOYS FOR THE KID, WHERE BETTER
TO GO THAN TAIWAN.
EVERYTHING IS MADE THERE.
THERE'S A PRETTY GOOD CHANCE SHE
WAS JUST SEEING LIKE WHAT ARE
YOU GUYS INVESTING IN, OH, IS
THIS A NEW PRODUCT?
IS THIS WE ARE GOING TO DO?
WHAT KIND OF TANK -- HEY, SOBER
UP, I NEED INVEST 20 ON THIS AND
THAT.
DO THIS, THAT.
SO I'M JUST SPECULATING.
IN THE OTHER SIDE OF IT IS AT
LEAST WE'VE GOT TO HAVE ONE
TOUGH PERSON IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
HEY, KIDS AT HOME, IF YOU EVER
WANT TO SUIT LOOKS LIKE ONE
ANOTHER COUNTRY HAS DIRT ON YOU,
WATCH OUR PRESIDENT RESPOND TO
CHINA THREATENING THE LEADER OF
OUR HOUSE.
THAT'S WHEN YOU'RE IN SOME OF
HIS BACK POCKET.
>> Greg: INTERESTING.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIE, DO YOU WISH YOU HAD A
LITTLE DONOR CARD TO GET YOU OUT
OF PROBLEMS?
>> YEAH, I COULD REALLY --
YOU'RE RIGHT, HE DOESN'T NEED
THIS KIND OF HELP, HE'S A
POWERFUL GUY.
I WOULD LOVE A CARD LIKE THAT.
I HEARD THAT BIDEN DID TRY TO
CALL PELOSI AND TELL HER NOT TO
GO.
BUT BY MISTAKE HE MADE THE CALL
ON HIS IRON.
HOW WAS THE PHONE CALL?
IT WAS HOTTER THAN I EXPECTED.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME -- MAYBE
I'M IGNORANT BUT THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME I'VE EVER HEARD THE
PHRASE SATYR REVELING IN MY
ENTIRE
LIFE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE MOST YOU
COULD GET AWAY WITH AT A STRIP
CLUB WITHOUT GETTING KICKED OUT.
>> Greg: I THINK THAT'S WHAT
IT MEANS.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> I FEEL LIKE HER HUSBAND'S GET
OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD SHOULD BE
THAT HE HAS TO BE MARRIED TO
HER.
I THINK THAT'S ENOUGH.
LIKE HAVE YOU SEEN MY WIFE, I
GOT DRUNK AND DROVE AWAY.
AND THEY WOULD BE LIKE OH, GET
ON WITH IT.
>> Greg: P.A.B., I THINK
WHAT'S MOST NAUSEATING IS THAT
HE'S A RICH DRUNK WHO TRIED TO
USE A PRIVILEGE CARD ON THE COPS
AND IT'S LIKE IF YOU'RE -- IT'S
KIND OF TACKY AND GROWS, THOSE
CARDS ARE FOR EVERYBODY ELSE,
NOT YOU.
>> ABSOLUTELY!
I ALSO LOVE THE FACT THAT IT
DIDN'T WORK.
GOT TO GIVE CREDIT TO THE COPS.
HE'S LIKE LOOK, HERE'S MY DONOR
CARD AND HE'S LIKE THAT'S NICE,
YOU'RE UNDER ARREST.
AND ONLY WANTS A REFUND.
SO I LOVE THE FACT THAT THE COPS
JUST SAID WE ARE GOING TO DO IT
ANYWAY.
BUT I HAVE TO AGREE WITH TYRUS
WHEN IT COMES TO WHY
NANCY PELOSI WENT OVER THERE.
IF YOU KNOW, PROBABLY A COUPLE
OF REASONS.
ONE, SHE WANTED TO GET AWAY FROM
HIM AS KAT SAID, AND ALSO SHE'S
TRYING TO MAYBE DRAW ATTENTION
AWAY FROM ALL OF THE PROBLEMS WE
HAVE HERE AND SHE GOT SOME
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR NOT
CAVING IN TO CHINA, SO I THINK
IT'S A WIN FOR HER BUT THE REAL
QUESTION IS WHY WAS BIDEN ON THE
OTHER SIDE?
>> Greg: IT'S INTERESTING.
AND IT'S WEIRD, IT DOES SOUND
FAMILIAR TO ME.
A COUNTRY WARNS US REPEATEDLY OF
A REDLINE AND WE CROSS IT AND
THEN THEY VIOLATE INTERNATIONAL
LAW AND YOU'VE GOT A WAR.
IT'S ON THE LITTLE BIT LIKE
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS ABOUT SIX
MONTHS A